Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vornachnamen langsam bestabieren?
Okay. Heinrich.
Heinrich, Emil, Ida, Nordpol, Richard, Ida, Cesar, Heinrich, Vorname Theodor, Heinrich, Ida, Emil, Theodor, Martha, Anton, Richard.
Herr Tietmann, wie anziehen Sie?
Entschuldigung?
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 53 Jahre alt, Doktor.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 2. Mai 1972.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter 80.
Und wie schwer sind Sie zuzeit?
Ich bin 60 Kilogramm.
60 Kilogramm. Danke für die Information. Herr Tietmann, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zuzeit?
Ich bin heute hier, weil ich ungefähr 1 Stunde starke Schmerzen habe.
Wo genau sind diese Schmerzen?
Meine Schmerzen sind in meinem Oberbauch.
Herr Tietmann, können Sie diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben? Sind sie eher drückend oder brennend stechend?
Die Schmerzen sind krampfartig, Doktor.
Und straten diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ja, ein bisschen in meinem Rücken.
Sind diese Schmerzen dauerhaft da oder gehen sie auch wieder weg?
Die sind dauerhaft.
Immer dauerhaft.
Ich verstehe.
Wie lange dauert diese krampfartige Schmerzen?
Ich glaube, Sie leiden unter Atake.
Wie lange dauert diese Atake?
Doktor, ich habe eine Minute diese Beschwerden.
Aber ich denke, 15 Minuten vielleicht.
Mit Atake.
Wie stark sind Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von SBCN-1 sehr leicht und sehr starke Schmerzen entspricht?
Ich würde sagen, Schmerzen sind 9.
10 auf der Skala 5.
Herr Tietmann, das ist eine sehr starke Schmerzen.
Ja, eine sehr starke Schmerzen, Doktor.
Soll ich Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel geben oder können Sie diese Schmerzen noch ein bisschen bis Ende des Sprechs aushalten?
Es wäre besser, wenn Sie eine Schmerzmittel geben können.
Ok, gerne.
Haben Sie Allergie gegen irgendwelche Medikamente, besonders Schmerzmittel?
Nein, ich habe keine Allergie gegen Schmerzmittel.
Leiden Sie an chronischen Nierenerkrankungen?
Nein, ich habe keine chronischen Nierenerkrankungen.
Ok, Schwester Müller, bitte geben Sie den Patienten ein Spasmolythika und einen Magenschutz.
Ok, Herr Tietmann, wie fühlen Sie sich jetzt besser?
Ja, ich bin jetzt besser. Danke, Doktor.
Sehr gerne.
Ok, bitte sagen Sie mir sofort Bescheid, wenn Sie noch Medikamente benötigen.
Ok, danke schön.
Herr Tietmann, haben Sie gegen diese Schmerzen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Ich nehme keine Medikamente, Doktor. Ich habe ungefähr 1 Stunde Schmerzen.
Ja, ich verstehe. Haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein, ich habe keine ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt.
Alles klar. Herr Tietmann, haben Sie eine bestimmte Auslöser für die Schmerzen bemerkt?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Ich meine nach dem Essen oder der stressigen Situation?
Ja, ja Doktor, Sie haben Recht.
Heute habe ich meiner Schwester zum Frühstück gegangen.
Ich esse viele Fettige essen. Nach dem Frühstück hat die Schmerzen sich bemerkt.
Ok, was haben Sie zum Frühstück gegessen, Herr Tietmann?
Ich habe Butter und ein bisschen Brot gegessen. Aber ich habe viele Butter mit Brot gegessen.
Ok, alles klar. Hat jemand ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt? Ich meine Ihre Schwester zum Beispiel oder nur Sie?
Ja, nur ich.
Ok, alles klar. Herr Tietmann, ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, mir ist auch übel. Aber ich möchte nicht übel geben, Doktor.
Ok, alles klar.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang?
Also ich meine, haben Sie Blut oder ungewöhnliche Situationen, Veränderungen im Stuhl bemerkt?
Ich habe keinen Apathit jetzt und leider Verstopfung. Aber diese Beschwerden sind nicht jetzt.
Diese Beschwerden sind sehr lange seit. Und dagegen nehme ich zweimal pro Woche Movicol.
Seit langem haben Sie Verstopfung und Sie nehmen Movicol dagegen?
Ja, pro Woche.
Herr Tietmann, haben Sie Hautfarbeveränderungen bemerkt? Ich meine Gelbsucht in den Augen oder an der Haut?
Ja, ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie keine Blutung oder kein Blut im Stuhlgang bemerkt?
Ja.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Ich habe keine Probleme mit Wasserlassen.
Das freut mich. Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Apathitlosigkeit haben.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zugenommen? Ich meine unwilkürlich?
Ja. Nein, ich habe immer gleichgewischt.
Fühlen Sie sich frieblich?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich habe keine Fieber. Nein.
Ok. Schüterfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Leiden Sie unter Luftnot oder Husten?
Nein, Doktor. Ich habe keine diese Schmerzen.
Herr Tietmann, ich muss fragen, ob Sie unter Brustschmerzen oder Herzrasen leiden?
Nein. Ich habe keine Brustschmerzen oder Herzrasen. Nein.
Das freut mich. Ok.
Sind Sie schon vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten oder Corona-Infektionen geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie z.B. Zuckerkrankheit oder Bluthochdruck?
Ja, seit ein paar Jahren habe ich Bluthochdruck. Damit habe ich Kandesartan behandelt.
Kandesartan, 8 mg?
Ja, 8 mg am Morgen.
Ok. Sie haben gesagt, seit langer Zeit. Was meinen Sie damit? 15 Jahre, 20 Jahre?
Ja, ungefähr 12 Jahre.
12 Jahre, ok. Noch sonst?
Ja, erhöhte Cholesterinwerte habe ich und dafür nehme ich Zimvostatin.
Welche Dosierung nehmen Sie ein? Und wie oft?
Ich erinnere mich nicht jetzt, Doktor.
Wie oft nehmen Sie ein?
Einmal täglich morgens.
Ok. Haben Sie eine Medikamentenliste dabei?
Ich habe keine Medikamente, nein.
Ok, kein Problem. Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Hausärztin?
Mein Hausarztname ist Yener Kaplan.
Ok, Herr Tietmann, ich werde Ihren Hausarzt kontaktieren und werde diese Medikamentenliste wieder kontrollieren.
Ok, danke.
Seit wann leiden Sie an erhöhte Cholesterinwerte?
Seit 5 Jahren.
Und sonst noch irgendwelche Erkrankungen haben Sie?
Ich habe auch eine Bandschreibung vor Ort, die ich mit Finalgon Salve behandle.
Benutzen Sie bei Bedarf oder regelmäßig?
Bei Bedarf, bei Bedarf.
Ok, in welchem?
Zwei Mal pro Woche oder dreimal.
In welchem Bereich ist das Problem? Ich meine Lendenbereich oder Halsbereich?
Lendenbereich, Doktor.
Seit wann haben Sie dieses Problem?
Ungefähr acht Jahre.
Ok, also.
Seit acht Jahren, ja.
Das war es, oder Herr Tietmann?
Entschuldigung.
Das war es oder haben Sie noch irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen?
Ich habe operiert.
Ich wurde früher wegen eines Nagelbruchs und wegen Arthrose am Fuß operiert.
Haben Sie gesagt Nagelbruch?
Ja, Nagelbruch, ja.
Nagelbruchoperation meinen Sie?
Und Sie haben gesagt Arthrose, ja?
Arthrose, ja. Wegen Arthrose am Fuß.
Am Fuß.
Ja. Operiert.
Als ich Kind war, hatte ich einen Unfall und meinen Nagelbruch.
Ich hatte Nagelbruch, ja.
Ich habe Nagelbruch, Entschuldigung.
Nagel, nicht Nagel.
Nabelbruch.
Ok.
Nagelbruch. Herr Tietmann, wenn ich richtig verstanden habe, wenn Sie als Kind waren, hatten Sie einen Nagelbruch?
Ja.
Und auch Sie hatten eine Operation wegen Arthrose am Fuß, richtig?
Ja, am Fuß. Vor zehn Jahren.
Vor zehn Jahren, ok.
Also ist das wegen einem Unfall oder ich meine diese Arthroseprobleme?
Ja, Arthroseprobleme. Kein Unfall, ja.
Ok, nur Arthrose.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein, außer genannten Medikamente?
Ja, ich habe alles gesagt Doktor. Ich habe keine anderen Medikamente.
Haben Sie eine Allergie gegen irgendwelche Pflanzmittel oder Nahrungsmittel?
Ja, ich habe Fruchtzuckerunverträglichkeit.
Wie äußert sich diese Fertiglichkeit?
Das führt bei mir zu Blähungen und Verdankbeschwerden. Verdankbeschwerden Doktor.
Alles klar. Herr Tietmann, rauchen Sie?
Entschuldigung. Außerdem habe ich eine Kursallergie wegen Pflanzmittel und Nahrungsmittel.
Das führt bei mir zu Schmerzen, Bauchschmerzen, Eczema und Yükreis.
Pflanzmittel und Nahrungsmittel.
Bauchschmerzen, Yükreis, Eczema haben Sie gesagt?
Ja, ja. Und Schmerzen.
Und Schmerzen.
Alles klar. Rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche seit meinem 17. Lebensjahr etwa 15 Zigaretten am Tag.
Und trinken 2 und 3 Flaschen Wein pro Woche.
Flaschen Wein pro Woche?
Ja, pro Woche.
Okay. Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, Drogen nehme ich keine Doktor.
Okay, das freut mich. Leiden Ihre Eltern an psychische Erkrankungen?
Ja, mein Vater ist mit 76 Jahren an Bauch, Speiser, Drüse, Krebs gestorben.
Ja, das freut mich. Und Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter hat eine Herzschwäche. Aber sie lebt noch.
Okay. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind Doktor.
Okay. Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe 3 Kinder.
Sind die Kinder gesund?
Ja, und sind sie gesund.
Okay, das freut mich. Was sind Sie von Beruf, Herr Tietmann?
Ich bin Bürokaufmann von Beruf.
Okay, alles klar. Und wohnen Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Ja, richtig. Ich lebe mit meiner Frau.
Okay, das waren meine Fragen. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe starke Schmerzen. Was habe ich?
Ja, also Herr Tietmann, es ist zu früh, eine sichere Diagnose zu stellen.
Aber ich vermute, dass Sie ein Problem mit Speichelbauchdüsen, also das kann eine Entzündung sein.
Deswegen werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Okay.
Okay Doktor. Ich warte auf Sie. Danke schön.
Ja, sehr gerne.
Heute habe ich nicht viel gesprochen, weil ich die Zeit zu spüren habe.
Die Zeit ist komplett vorbei.
Herr Aydin, Sie haben die Zeit sehr gut genutzt.
Ich habe dann Gas gegeben. Ich habe dann gesehen, dass es wieder geht.
Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen zu den Anamnesen zu stellen.
Aber ich kann nur das hier missen.
Wie du die Medikamente nicht angenommen hast.
Ich habe die Anamnesen gesagt, aber es gibt noch andere Anwendungen.
Er hat es gesagt. Er hat es gefragt.
Er hat es gefragt, ob Sie noch eine Medikamentation angenommen haben.
Ich erinnere mich an etwas.
Ja, ich habe es gefragt.
Wo ist unser Editor?
Ja, ihr Editor.
Er ist ein Pro.
Ja, generell ist es gut.
Herr Aydin, Sie haben die Zeit.